there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey it's us again and it's
episode 143 going back to the true crime
like we do yeah this is a request one
these actually these were both requests
but I wanted to do them I wanted to
specifically do them on one show just
one because the first case isn't like
super detailed because it happened a
long time ago but both of these cases
also I've wrote about them in my books
like the first case I wrote about in the
first faceless villain volume and the
second case I'm writing about it in this
next one that's coming out which is
volume 3 yeah which as I said will be
out hopefully at the end of the summer
or early fall yeah and if we sound
different we're having problems with a
microphone again again again this is the
new this is the second blue Yeti that we
bought ok it's like we bought one used
off eBay yeah and it works fine for a
while but then it started doing this
weird thing and like I don't know if
it's a Mac problem I don't know because
I record this on a Mac got a feeling
it's some kind of software from I took
this that one apart and looked at it I
thought maybe there's a connection in
the jack with a wire no like it still
works but for a while like when you
bought so that one kind of went tits-up
and we bought a brand new one allegedly
and it works fine until yesterday when
all of a sudden it still works but all
of a sudden the max doesn't recognize it
as a Yeti anymore yeah it forgets the
settings like it just comes up is like a
generic yeah USB microphone instead of
because you know it used to come up when
you plugged it into the Mac it used to
come up and said yeti stereo microphone
that's what they're both that's what
they're both doing and we researched it
and it's gotta be some kind of software
conflict I mean it still works just you
have to manually go in there and do the
settings and we can't depend on that for
the audiobook yeah so we went we got a
professional system yeah I got one of
those would
8020 35s with that damn let they call it
the the thing that turns it into digital
so you can put it in there and I didn't
get the preamp but I might you know yeah
we went ahead and got pretty much like a
sort of like basic professional system
it's something I can trust it's got the
boom arm on it and I can yeah I mean not
so much like I said it's you know
recording for the podcast as long as it
sounds you know decent that's fine but
like when I do the audiobooks I really
want them to sound you know as good as
possible yeah so I didn't it sucks
because I'd already recorded like seven
or eight chapters with this microphone
and now I'm gonna have to do them all
perfect ends are they all out sound
consist we got two blue yetis for sale
if anybody wants them for a good price I
mean yeah they're good it's you know
skipper podcasting like I said they
still work it sorted I didn't really
trust them for and they might work
better on PC it might just be a Mac
issue yeah I feel like me my god so we
have a wire for that one too right
yes one of them's new in the box the
other one is with outside the box you
know I'll give you a deal on it yeah so
if anybody wants like a because how much
do they new honey there aren't ten
hundred ten someone give that one for
about forty yeah I think we bought that
used one on eBay for fifty or sixty yeah
while back and it lasted a few months
and then it started like I said it still
works it's just the Mac doesn't
recognize it and I'm getting like yeah
anyway loses our settings so when it
comes to doing audiobooks you got to
make sure that it's perfectly consistent
and I don't trust it yeah that's what I
said so this one here we got the box for
it and everything apart of that then go
for about 80 yeah
but yet so we bought it on Mac issue too
so it might be because I've seen there
like a lot of people had problems like a
lot of it wasn't like compatible with
Macs and stuff so it might just be the
fact that I'm recording this on my you
know oh yeah yeah MacBook that might be
the problem - yeah so we went ahead and
bit the bulletins you a lot of money in
50 bucks I'm likely to 50 to 230 230
yeah yeah it was generally yeah yeah so
we went ahead and kind of got a
semi-professional like a basic
professionals
I'll be able to sing with that [ __ ] -
yeah we do some karaoke we've been
thinking about doing some carry yeah but
this thing I'm gonna do is I would do
like some some dancing covers yeah she
was priest covers can you do you should
do some Roy Orbison also do Roy Orbison
and Bowie yeah yeah I'll do kind of
gothic versions of them yeah that'd be
totally yeah that'd be that'd be like
that's like your friend's good trip
that's like your friends band that does
the goth covers of like cheesy 80s songs
yeah death in Rome if you have like what
the month they do like they do a cool
cover of take on me they did love is a
battlefield that's my favorite they did
Careless Whisper yeah yeah I think
there's it's all on YouTube um was it
pump up the jams no did they did yeah I
don't remember that one they did the
Siam yeah yeah they did the sign - yeah
from that I remember I was trying to
think I was thinking was that aqua I was
like no that's Barbie girl I can't
remember who did it but you know I saw
this yeah if you like if you like death
and Jun go check out death and Rome yeah
yeah well it's funny to me because
hearing the songs it's like if you
didn't know that there's what like if
you didn't know for example that that
was a cover of like a pat benatar sargon
AHA song yeah you'd be like oh that's a
cool like goth sounding song I sing it
slow and dark yeah I don't think I've
heard that one actually I have a bunch
of my phone yeah that's not one of them
yeah so yeah go check him out like I
said all that most of their stuff's on
youtube I think all right so as I said
episode of hundred 2143 rather and we
are doing more true-crime we're doing
two cases that occurred in Sweden now
they were 50 years apart but I decided
to do them on the same show because wand
they're both in Sweden Sweden tonight
yes we are - the victims were both
prostitutes and three they were
particularly gruesome and weird okay
murders so the first of them is simply
called the Atlas vampire case that comes
from the 1930s and
second one is the murder of Catrin
DeCosta which comes from 1984 and is
actually the loose basis of Stieg
Larsson's international bestseller The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo like this is
where he got the idea for it and kind of
like the media that does you know that
kind of happened in the week of this
particular murder good movies actually
yeah well the books honestly I love
those books I read them I think I read
all three of them in one single weekend
well you have time to read that new Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo it wasn't bad I
liked that one I did too actually
yeah girl Bond flick yeah I like it you
know that was a new it wasn't Naomi and
I always kind of knew he's kind of she's
kind of old for that role now I think
yeah be in her 40s by now he doesn't
look it but she's got a vision I can't
remember yeah it was pretty good though
was it okay now which one cuz I know I
saw both versions I saw because the
original trilogy they did it in Swedish
and then they did an American version
also so I think the American version had
Daniel Craig in it now that I'm thinkin
yeah and then nobody were paced ones
were also and they were Swedish okay so
maybe she was the original yeah I can't
remember now I can't remember who played
her in the they were both good like I
remember I remember liking the Swedish
ones in the in your loans that's the
only problem there well it's a very um
convoluted story like but like at the
books I like that too but they totally
like just sucked me in like I started
reading the first one and I think I
stayed up the food like at the first
book I just stayed up like all night
reading it cuz I couldn't put it down
I knew what I had in mind a new one we
saw in the theater they came but Kimmy
came out a few months back was a little
more fast pages almost kinda like an
action movie I liked it though yeah I
think they're trying stuff even though
like I said I'm pretty sure that Stieg
Larsson died but I think they're trying
to do like another trilogy trilogy or
like reboot the franchise a little bit
which is you know that's fine with me
cuz I like that character I like
Elizabeth slender she's like a cool
character but yeah so the second case
we're gonna talk about the prostitute
murder that happened in Sweden in the
80s was actually the case that inspired
Stieg Larsson's to write the first book
so there you go alright so before we get
into the true crime weirdness
just have a couple of shoutouts today
got two very nice generous PayPal
donations this week or I guess in the
last couple weeks cuz like I said we
don't record these regularly anymore we
try to get like a few ahead but so we
got some donations from Melanie who
sends us donations pretty much every
month or every couple months
um so thank you very much it's also one
from Jason now like I said um I think
that cuz Jason was actually the first
person that clued me into this was that
the PayPal button that was on our blog
cuz you know at the end I always say you
know want to give a PayPal donation go
like go to the blog and there's a little
PayPal button um that wasn't working so
I had to go in there and fix it but I
fixed it now so it's working fine if you
yes we don't like to do a patron so if
you just want to send us some money on
PayPal it's good yeah everybody just
give us a dollar that'd be six grand
because we busted six grand in terms of
we did I wanted to like mention that
it's like I keep forgetting like I keep
forgetting what I want to imagine but
yeah we finally did get over 6000
subscribers on YouTube so thank you very
much guys finally made it yeah
I know it took a while yeah we got if we
got to 4,000 pretty quickly yeah seemed
like it
maybe was even the whole way how it is I
don't know it seems like the first
thousand took a while or hard it was
like a hard slog then next thing you
know it was like three or three things
yeah and then it kind of sped up and
they're you know I don't know like I
said weird yeah we're not super like we
keep track of it he probably keeps track
closer track of it than I do like I kind
of glanced it up like you know whatever
I'm just kind of worried about producing
the show and it's still making sure it's
good and making sure it comes out on
time he got into the high five thousands
and it stalled out for a long time and
then I'll boom it came back yeah yeah
but yeah so just weird I had to do it
wasn't just us it was everybody they
were messing with those algorithms well
I actually it's funny because I got a
little what you call it
they YouTube sent me a little Creator
not a well not a quiz what's the word
I'm looking for a survey they sent me a
little survey about what I liked about
YouTube what I didn't like about YouTube
like cuz oh so I guess they're like
messing with some
stuff like trying to make it better for
people so I went in there and like you
know answered their little questions and
stuff like that yeah but yeah we're
getting your messages on Facebook and
Tom shitty movies I got I got my own
little channel on Facebook called Tom's
shitty movies with SH I D dy and now I
keep forgetting I haven't been messing
with it lately though we've been busy
you know watching too many shitty mundo
with two DS know what we've been so busy
lately
well yeah cuz we were watching movies to
review I've been because I got excited
because I saw Netflix they posted the
third season of ash vs. Evil Dead so I'm
like okay well we gotta watch that but
then like I kept watching it that I kept
falling asleep cuz right because our
kitty wakes us up so early that I fall
asleep at like 10:00 in the morning we
have to do movie reviews nicely so we
gotta watch movies yeah we have to go to
the theatre yeah
boy it's [ __ ] breaking me down I'm
watching these movies so you people
don't have to tell you these movies
we'll see not really like the ones this
I think the ones this week and actually
by the time this show goes up people
will have already seen the matinee show
the ones this week actually turned out
better than I was expecting
Jerrica I thought yeah you know they
weren't fantastic there okay well I
thought you liked him at the time yeah
like you're just being crabby right yeah
like they're okay you know they're not
bad but they're not great either but I
think most movies are like that yeah
well like I said most movies have been
like that forever yeah I think you were
like that forever most of our forgotten
yeah you only just remember the good
ones because that's why you remember
them cuz they were really good
you don't remember like all the forty
million other shitty right everybody
forgot about like in the 80s
particularly like a let's [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of movies came on babies that were
just like terrible and forgettable
alright so it's gonna give this case
let's go back to 1932 okay and talk
about the case known as the Atlas
vampire and you will shortly see 32 1932
okay now this took place in Stockholm
Sweden and there was a neighborhood
called the Atlas neighborhood
which is why this case called the
endless vampire no apparently gift thank
you so alright so apparently like a lot
of prostitutes and whatnot like lived in
this particular area so there's this
woman that lived there who was a
prostitute she was 32 years old her name
was Lily
Linda strim and she was actually and I
suppose this was unusual for the time um
you know because most prostitutes back
then probably as now well I guess not
now but back then mostly street
prostitutes didn't have too many quote
unquote call girls like people come into
your house like you'd make an
appointment and people would come over
and stuff like that but that's what this
girl was doing so she was a little bit
ahead of her time I guess in the in the
whole prostitution game hmm
so she yes so she ran her own like
prostitution business out of her
apartment now she also had um a neighbor
and I think the neighbor lived
downstairs and her neighbors name was
Minnie Jansen and she was 35 and she was
also a prostitute so I guess the two of
them were friends and they kind of like
looked out for each other and stuff so
one night and this is in like late April
early May 1932 so Lily comes downstairs
and knocks on Minnie's door and asked if
she can borrow some condoms and now
Minnie said that that was kind of a
pretty common thing I guess Lily was
always running out of condoms you know
you never have enough hanging around the
house I guess she she had a rush and it
was Barry so she said yeah she was
always coming down sometimes she'd just
be naked or just have a robe on or
something she's just like a hanging mini
can I borrow some condoms and she said
sure she said it was about 9 o'clock at
night so she gives you the condoms Lily
goes by says thank you very much and she
goes back upstairs presumably to
entertain whatever client she had up
there so then a couple of days go by and
many thinks to herself gee I haven't
seen Lily around in a couple of days
that's a little weird so she calls her
apartment no answer she goes up there
knocks them
or again no answer so she's like okay
this is [ __ ] up so she calls the
police so the police come over and they
bust into the flat and in Lilly's
bedroom they find Lilly Linda strum she
is dead she's clearly been dead for a
couple of days
she's lying face down in her bed her
head has been kind of bashed in with a
blunt instrument presumably there is I
think they're like her clothes were very
neatly folded like on a chair next to
the bed there is still a condom sticking
out of her anus oh that has semen in it
damn and almost all of her blood is gone
okay now you get to back up all her
Bloods gone pretty much it's not know
was there an incision on her no huh
how does that happen see this is why
they called the kc atlas vampire now the
only other thing they found in the
apartment was a gravy ladle that had
like some traces of blood in it so near
as they could figure the person that
killed her came into the apartment and
dragged her blood with the ladle but
they couldn't figure out okay they're
like one she was clearly beaten to death
in the head and what I I read on this
one site that apparently the way because
there was still you know the condom
sticking out of her butt and the fact
that she had died like from blunt force
trauma to the back of the head they said
maybe that Don mean this was presumably
the last client that she had going in
but they we don't yeah it was charged
one after that right unless somebody
came after that was like an Oreo that's
what I you know what you know what it's
like it's it's but yeah some camera
that's what I me they're more Ted Bundy
he'd go back maybe all about that they
come in there and be like oh when win
they'd be all rotten and everything I
don't even have to pay the cops are like
why the hell were you going back there
they're late Jesus it was free like I
said just like when you put food just
like when you put jelly and hot sauce on
your sausage and biscuits it's free yeah
at Waffle House because they're free she
gets on me about that because this is a
whole southern thing they never made a
few you said it's free any time around
Mississippi or Alabama you go to the old
wards guys no awards is you get a
biscuit with sausage
all right sausage biscuit well didn't
have anything on it but they got hot
sauce and they got jelly they're for
free so you put that on it it's good
sweet spot it's not that yeah it's not
that way and then I later I made her try
it yes yeah that's good it's it like
it's not that weird I just badass
awesome jelly graduate you pick on you
because you do well no because like what
is what is that every day which Monte
Cristo yeah for you British pedaling
Monte Cristo what are you British people
that are out there you're always getting
[ __ ] confused about what jelly is
okay jelly is not gelatin or jello okay
jelly for us is like preserves preserves
but preserves them they're not made with
pectin again yeah what would you call
preserves preserves are just preserved
what's your jam the British would call
it jam but really have whole fruit in it
it's like kind of mushed up fruit and
yeah stuff but jelly doesn't have fruit
in its like jam without fruit
it's like jam made with fruit juice yeah
it's totally clear I've made jelly
before yeah I made it my home in class
in high school actually yeah it's
basically its fruit juice and pectin and
some other [ __ ] I can't right away not a
lot of things so one which I've got
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches we're
talking about peanut butter jam on
toasted bread with butter on that [ __ ]
okay well yeah if you want to make these
British you would understand this they
don't understand
[ __ ] man they laugh at us for that I
offered a peanut butter jelly sounds to
a British woman one time it was over
here over here visiting and she was a No
No thank you that's you turn it down
peanut butter her husband says you
better to accept this they do peanut
butter you weren't here for dad cuz yeah
I think you were here for that anyway
gonna move our betters move on well I'm
like I said it's not just peanut butter
also almond butter and yeah cashew
butter that's right it's really cuz I
see all these videos on youtubes these
European people making fun of us for
eating peanut butter how's it happening
man we know how to make peanut butter
you know what to do with peanut butter
and well peanuts in general or really
act like peanuts in candy bars or you
never had a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
yeah I thought they had those over there
no man tell you what when I was living
in Boston they had a candy shop down in
Cambridge Square yeah it's probably
still there it's right there I'm near
the key right there near the pit right
there near we call just call it the pits
for all the little punk rock kids and
the goth kids used to hang outside t
stop Cambridge T stop right across T
from Harvard there was candy candy shop
that used to make their own candy and
they made peanut butter cups the size of
a [ __ ] Apple that's something they
were like that [ __ ] tall and that big
around they're like that big around that
tall God they were good and had a couple
different flavors one of the flavors was
peanut butter and grape jelly inside the
dam alright
and I think it was white chocolate okay
now yeah because here's the thing one of
my one of my very favorite things and
Reese's does this and like I've had some
from like better candy stores are
actually better but a peanut butter
peanut butter cup made with white
chocolate yo yeah with yet it was peanut
butter with great jelly yes I know white
chocolate is technically not chocolate
you could get fat just looking at those
[ __ ] you didn't have I think they
were like $5 a cup cuz my metabolism
hates your like $5 a cup and you could
only eat one it would be like big is
that piece of the biggest that tape it's
like that yeah I would eat them anyway
like there was probably weighed almost a
half a pound
if but that would be the only thing I
would eat all day and then I would throw
it up later but it would probably taste
just as good
okay let's get back into the show so
yeah okay so not only this like I said
they find the gravy ladle that has like
sort of you know smears of blood in it
also they found like sticky saliva like
on the back like on her back and
shoulders as though the dude had like
licked her yeah like you it and what
they thought like I said and I think
this is what I was getting at before we
went off on a tangent about peanut
butter cups was that I read a site that
said because of the way the the condom
was still in her butt and because she
had been like beat up you know in the
back of the head someone presumed that
while they were anally penetrating her
let's put it that way
that they were doing what they would
call a donkey pop yes that and they
don't know but they've resumed the
verities style of donkey punch but it
was yeah killer donkey what should he
mean - I don't know yeah of course you
can't you can't do that by accident you
can't beat something death by accident
and you know you have to requires effort
yeah donkey punch
donkey punches she's a playful threat
yeah they don't actually kill a person
or hit the parole I what does that be
[ __ ] up pop like yeah yeah that's like
one of those weird things but it's like
oh I'm gonna stop myself
that was didn't have donkey punches in
the 1930s that was somebody trying to
kill a [ __ ] what that was
he probably want to pay maybe not yeah
and that's an en like who didn't like
[ __ ] yeah that's the mentality there's
I don't like these [ __ ] but see okay
that's the you know Gary wedge way Gary
Ridgway had that problem I'm having
sexual problems yeah here we go
well that's what they that's what they
call Oh men have sexual problems
yeah well does he act clearly did it
that's what they would call a mission
focused
or mission
yeah motivated killer because it's like
they think that they're punishing people
who are transgressing from some
imaginary moral code like I don't like
hookers I don't like gay people I don't
like this and the other thing so they
think they're punishing you so it's like
some weird righteous thing yeah well I
feel like Jack the Ripper might have had
that yeah a lot of my head that yeah I'm
pretty sure Ridgeway had that I think
Rader had that hmm
but Raiders also kind of like
embarrassed of himself too cuz I'd be
embarrassed even dressed up like he was
a bad girl you know and bury himself and
take pictures of gonna spank me yeah
yeah not taking pictures of himself in
his [ __ ] stockings [ __ ] there's Mary
we're honest in his garter sexy ass
Dennis well you know how it is sometimes
you know sometimes a man needs a good
photograph you know can't find the
models you're gonna use yourself you
know sometimes I'm a bad girl you know
oh my god okay sometimes a man has to be
a bad girl you know I seriously that
audio clip of you saying sometimes have
a bad girl hmm
I am gonna keep that probably and I'm
already I've been drinking you know so
I'm with it I'm gonna talk [ __ ] that's
I'm gonna do you know I'm trying to yeah
well here's what's funny and I I wanted
to mention sometimes I'm gonna channel
Dennis okay you know I'm gonna mention
this on this show now just because the
other night you said this and I thought
it was funny
yeah is that we were um we were playing
with our Kitty baby cookie which you
guys will know yeah and he says just
kind of apropos of nothing he's like
I've suddenly become the kind of man who
talks baby talk to a cat yeah you know
I'm a morning I was like and yeah well I
was young when I was a younger man
No when I was a younger man I'd see
these guys you know I've come out of the
service you know and I'd see these
suckas soft a civilian [ __ ]
talking baby talk to [ __ ] dogs into
cats and [ __ ] I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden now I'm that
guy I'm Donaghy talking to you talking
yeah talk to the kitty but the but see
that's what did you learn that there's
nothing wrong with that
no there's something wrong wrong with it
but I've accepted it I've accepted that
I do that accepted that there's not I've
accepted that guy you know to mean what
Conan do that [ __ ] no Conan would not do
that
he better [ __ ] do that with sergeant
Todd do that from the soldier no
sergeant Todd wouldn't do that
some would Snake Plissken do that [ __ ]
no yeah but they're sociopaths call it
whatever you wanna call call it whatever
you want I have to tell you though just
from a female perspective maybe talking
to the kitty and I'm not speaking you
know I would never presume to like speak
for the entire female gender but the
second dude is like picks up a kitty and
goes kitty
I'm just like I love that [ __ ] I
especially love dudes that love kitties
look listen I like dogs too let's
continue with the show you try to
embarrass me never start channeling
Raider
Dennis Rader you've already done that
okay I'm gonna start channeling him all
right so here's the weird thing
so Lily Linda strum like I said the only
wound as far as I know and like I said
this happened in 1932 as far as I know
the only wound they found on her was the
wound that killed her which was the you
know blunt-force trauma to the back of
the head no incisions no nothing almost
all of her blood was gone there was no
there was hardly any blood on the bed
there was no blood on the rope
who this girl did they cut her open try
to find out where this where how she
lost his blood nah I don't could it be
possible he ruptured her internally and
drank it from from from one of her
orifices yeah they might have like
thought of that because I think that I
mean they were kind of operating on the
assumption
they're like look this dude like scooped
the blood up with the gravy ladle and
drank it or he brought a syringe and
drank it from the syringe or he took it
with him or he had some kind of like
suction device or he was an actual
vampire maybe he had a needle and he
stuck it in a carotid artery they did
like think of that that maybe he had
brought something but you need like a
big [ __ ] I mean that would say why I
think there's about it what a gallon and
a half of blood in the body what is it
12 pints I thought it was I don't think
it was two gallons maybe he brought like
a big [ __ ] maybe brought some of your
big [ __ ] Kukulcan jars and right you
knew you would need a bunch of those
yeah you just might need a whole lot of
time that's what I mean well or you just
story it was last meeting with you she
was last seen like two days before they
found her dead I think it was two or
three days so he could have like hung
out the only the only other case that I
can think of it was like this was what
was the name Richard chase yeah Richard
chase the vampire killer from California
is back in the 70s yeah and once a
person is dead you're the heart isn't
pumping so it's kind of hard to get the
blood out of the body so yeah you can
play a kind of sluggish you have to make
a pretty big incision and then you kind
of have to like usually they go inside
like the abdomen and they try to scoop
it out of there was something like a cup
he was he'd go to the garbage you can go
get a cup like old [ __ ] used me going
to the woman's car catching garbage and
get like a whole used yogurt cup and try
to [ __ ] them scooped it up out of there
and drink as much of his equally big
gulp yeah but they can't blood but you
can't really get it all that's on see
that's what weird me out about this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I said it's from 1932
so I don't know like from the accounts
of it I don't know how much blood was
actually at the scene I have seen like a
couple of photographs of it and it
doesn't really look like there's any I
couldn't really see any blood sure but
it's old how much more of this case is
there not really not much I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say the Swedes [ __ ] up and
they assumed this
she had been blood and bled dry probably
most of her blood was still in her
that's what I'm gonna say
I think they [ __ ] up somehow it's hard
to get all every drop of blood out of
somebody like it I don't think it was
every drop but they're just saying most
of it was gone and there wasn't any cash
or there wasn't a large amount like or
in the area you know what I mean I can't
see yeah other than in the ladle the
only way you're gonna be able to do that
was some kind of bombing equipment or
some kind of surgical equipment maybe it
was a funeral dude maybe you came in
with like some embalming [ __ ] no this is
my fetish yeah and if you did it in
another way you're gonna make a mess
yeah I mean so the only clean way that's
something kind of like surgical or some
kind of bombing he would do it
postmortem and then you take that
equipment away you know maybe you could
do it that way but you know I'm just
thinking this is highly unlikely I think
it's more likely that the investigators
made a mistake that she wasn't missing
blood that's what I'm thinking I don't
know man how do they know she's missing
all this blood well I presume they did
post-mortems they knew how to do
post-mortems in the 1930s you know
everything I mean they they knew how
much blood was supposed to be in there
as opposed to how much blood is now in
there maybe she was very dehydrated or
something at the time I don't know that
and they they made some kind of
miscalculation it's gotta be some have
an error I don't know that's just what
I'm saying I'm saying there was no signs
of any kind of massive trauma there's no
one sister Lizzie were mad other than to
her head but there wasn't any blood
spilled anywhere you beat somebody's
head in enough to kill him you know what
I mean there's gonna be some blood yeah
there was a bit but not not as much as
but if she bleeds to death is the blood
would be everywhere so that's not what
happened right except it was in the
gravy ladle that's the only other place
they found you know that was human blood
yeah
at least in the 30s they could tell the
difference between human blood and
animal blood and I think they could even
tell what blood type is how do you get
blood out of that girl and get it into
that ladle that's what everybody is what
is why they call this the Atlas vampire
case because they feel like somebody
came in there and took most from blood
and either drank it or took off with it
and did some other [ __ ] with it that
nobody knows about and the weird thing
about it too is that I think they I mean
obviously she's a prostitute so they had
to you know go and talk it to all of her
like former clients and all of this
other stuff I think they had about nine
suspects at one point but all of them
were eventually cleared lack of evidence
and whatnot and there were really no
other similar crimes to that it seemed
like a one-off which is unusual because
this seems like a serial killer motif
but they didn't have any other crimes
that were like that that happened over
that time period so I kind of feel like
this was almost maybe it was a personal
vendetta of some sort maybe he beat her
senseless she didn't die from the
beating but then he put it he put some
kind of IV in her and pump the blood out
of her what I mean was having sex with
her during that time and then he left
with the blood yeah maybe or something
like that that's what I'm saying like I
feel like this was maybe this might have
been some guy that had visited her
previously so maybe he kind of knew her
but maybe he had like this weird [ __ ]
fetish and maybe he was even building
[ __ ] up overtime like getting a little
bit weird or a little bit weird a little
bit weirder and then he shows up at her
place and he's like hey you know I have
this thing about um you know drawing
blood and it's like is that okay and
maybe if she was kind of like okay
whatever man-- and then she didn't
realize she was beaten unconscious how
far it would go
she was beaten unconscious though she
would just lay there with the needles in
place and then her heart pumping the
blood out of her but whatever yeah into
into a bag yeah and you know some serial
killers have really been into things
like an atom
medical stuff oh yeah you know cuz
Dahmer was into all that stuff so maybe
he had planned for that he may have
wanted her blood for some reason or he
had some kind of fantasy about having
sex with a woman as she was dying
cuz I'm sure the bet that sex was
postmortem as she was [ __ ] unconscious
dying from blood loss he's having sex
with her I kind of feel like that's kind
of what I'm feeling as well like because
like I said I feel like I mean obviously
the the condom that was still in her but
had semen in it so obviously he was
doing that he was perhaps punching her
in the head either booze fist or with
some other instrument that I deal with
an object yeah Hildur he prizes that
strong he's probably that's what I was
yeah with and then I was laying there in
a coma he hooked her up to the second IV
bags and stuff and she pumped all her
blood out of maybe the carotid artery or
something and he's raping her yeah and
then then he collects the blood unhooks
everything just leaves the condom in
place is kind of like because it's kind
of degrading or something you know and
then he just walks out of there with her
blood you know he might have two or
three bags of that blood yeah before she
actually her heart stopped beating you
know and who knows maybe maybe he sells
the blood and he's a medical student or
something or yeah although like I said
it's only something like a fetishistic
sounds like fetish yeah I mean you know
weird but I've heard weirder you don't
steal the blood just to sell it you know
had enough for it but you might be a
fetish there might be a fetish thing of
having sex with somebody dying of blood
loss and then now you got the blood yeah
this just got cause it's like I got her
soul type of deal you know I mean you
keep that around your frigerator for a
little while maybe you drink some of it
but maybe you sell it to I don't know I
do kind of feel like that's kind of a
price right he probably the only thing
that that bothers me about that is that
there were no other crimes like that in
the area like something like that a
fetishistic type of crime at that
specific of fetish well maybe wasn't
that good so he so he's like I'm just
gonna go back to doing the regular
yes I wanted him so I did he didn't do
it again yeah maybe it wasn't as cool as
yeah it's [ __ ] up but like I said I
read about these cases all the time
that's like these people do some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] but yeah so it's sad because it
I feel like he left so much physical
evidence behind I mean they had his
semen they had a saliva they had all
this other [ __ ] that he left there and
I'm not sure but like they're like her
clothes were left on the chair they're
like did she fold that they were very
neatly folded like on the chair did she
do that or did he do that like after he
left like they thought maybe he had OCD
or something she did maybe but it's just
it's just super weird case and it's
funny because I was reading one account
of it and there's not a lot about this
case in English anyway but there's this
one woman and she had written a blog
post about it and she actually lived in
the same building as this woman had
lived in back in the thirties even
though she lived like in the other side
of it and she said now there's um this
kind of closed in like corridor that
goes between the two buildings like
where and like the laundry room is in
there so they're like maybe the killer
could have come and gone through there
and no one would have seen him because
nobody apparently saw this dude I mean
they interviewed so many people they
interviewed like even her friend many
who was right downstairs and they were
both prostitutes and they knew each
other
like I said they borrowed condoms from
each other all the time and she didn't
see anybody nobody saw anybody leaving
or coming in guarantees one of her
regular customers she was comfortable
with I'm Kay yeah I'm kind of feeling
like that problem and it kind of like
built up to that I feel like it builds
up to that they probably interviewed him
yeah and they passed interview and he
was just like yeah somebody she knew
well and like it's sad because I feel
like man a lot of these prostitutes you
just that's what happens may be coming
in contact with sketchy dudes yeah and
these sketchy dudes know that well you
know she comes up miss and then you know
then there's gonna be so many suspect
suspects and she moves a lot and they
won't be a lot to go on so many guys are
running out of here day you know I mean
that's like maybe 50 25 sets that's
possible suspect per day yeah
yeah I mean it's uh yeah too much
traffic yeah well like I said that's why
a lot of them end up dead and I like I
said the next case we're talking about
it was just Catrin decosta it was the
same kind of thing where you know and
and the same thing happened I think I
mentioned it on our show about the
highway of tears and all that other kind
of stuff it's like you know you're a
prostitute you're hitchhiking or
whatever it's like you know I hate to
say that but you're kind of you're not
asking for it obviously nobody is but
you're just putting yourself into a
situation where it's just easy it's easy
for some guy who is a [ __ ] predator to
just be like hey no one's gonna miss
this chick or no one's gonna look for
this chick or there'll be too many
suspects nobody associates me with her
so I'm just gonna kill her and [ __ ]
dump her on the side of the road
transport donor blood transient
population z-- women with high traffic
zones in front of their houses I eat
prostitutes it's just it's easy yeah
easy transient populations people coming
and going places where people are coming
going all the time yeah that's
investigators have a hard time finding
people under those circumstances yeah
thus that's why HH Holmes and the the
big fair that would the World's Fair
there was happening Chicago what year
was that 19 oh gosh I got there early
nineteen hundred's he called it you know
he knew that well are gonna have all
these people in all this traffic from
around the world to come to this World's
Fair I'll be able to kill these people
and [ __ ] the investigators and never
figure it out and no one will ya know I
really didn't know no well that's what I
mean it's like I don't know if he killed
as many people as they think but I don't
know there there's no way of knowing
because so many people pass through that
city and they're like oh hey I don't
heard from aunt Helen in awhile wonder
what ever happened to her she went to
the World's Fair and Herbert Emory yeah
Cobb cuz he killed somebody who's
connected to him and yeah that's
somebody he knew and that's how the you
get caught well yeah and I think that's
again why a lot of serial
killers and why like you know whoever is
stalking the highway of tears the Texas
killing fields all these others I'm sure
it's much more than one person but yeah
I'm sure it's truck drivers also but
because they're targeting hitchhikers
because they're targeting you know
prostitutes lot lizards that type of
person it's like no one's going to
connect to you if there's no connection
to the victim
yeah there's no in like there's no way
you don't know where to start
a lot of times the victim doesn't have
any family or stable family and really
or their family doesn't know where they
are
yeah and almost the same thing a lot of
times if they find an unidentified body
and they can't link it to anybody and
there isn't any family screaming they
can't you know about solving some bodies
murder nothing really happens with those
cases yeah well like I said I read about
those all the time it's like it's yeah
just go to Detroit if you don't believe
me go to Detroit look at what's
happening in Detroit if you're a 40 year
old black male indigent on welfare and
you come up missing those cops can't
find you did they don't have the
resources yeah yeah I mean like I said
that's a collapsing city and that's the
[ __ ] highest that's what they call
the highest risk population there you
know I mean it's a shrinking population
lots of violence actually it's down to
now now almost like when you look at
Detroit you know cuz I lived in Detroit
for a few years Detroit's almost
becoming like small town in a way
they're tearing it all down as it [ __ ]
disintegrates into nothing weird we're
saving a second you know there was a
whole culture there and everything about
making machines Ginny and I talked about
it every now and then
back from the theater I was like NASA
[ __ ] weird those guys giving tours of
it online on YouTube as they drive
around showing you Detroit and you can
watch it disappear
you can watch old factories you know
them in places where I used to work in
part time yeah I mean it's empty now
it's like part of a diet and part of a
dead culture vanished well it's you know
everything is are these temporary
ephemeral yeah everything is transient I
don't know I don't I'm not as bothered
by it as you are I don't think like oh
well it's old it's no I always have a
concept of progress that you get one
thing done then you built up on that and
then it builds and it builds know how it
goes it's going all over the place yeah
there's really there's no I mean it's
it's not like a straight-ahead or no now
a huge metropolis can vanish into dust
yeah just go to Europe and look at
[ __ ] the ancient cities that are
[ __ ] gone you know that's like I'm
not saying it's not sad it's just it
doesn't bother me because it's not that
for each whole population so culture is
languages everything just came yeah
banished yeah it's like I said it's sad
it's a shame but there's nothing you can
do about this just the nature of
existence
I don't know it just it doesn't bother
me all that while I was talking I was
immune no why would you think that I
don't know there's just something about
it you know you think you're immune to
it hmm that's interesting yeah
I don't know I wonder why it's like I've
heard a lot of people say that
especially I think especially when
they're younger especially a teen
there's just stuff oh my I feel I'm
gonna die young you think you might
never felt like that ever I don't
understand why people ever thought that
well I was like you thought you were
immortal really started I never thought
nobody's saying that I'm not saying that
I'm just saying that as I got into my
late 30s or early for my early forties I
realized that the things that I took for
granted was temporary [ __ ] mmm-hmm
yeah yeah that's weird I don't know I
was I was a weird person I guess like
you're always a freakazoid oh yeah yeah
no I'm owning that right now because
even when I was
a kid I was just like yeah I'm gonna die
someday and all this is gonna be gone oh
well that's what happens well I was kind
of hit that 1950s kind of mentality to
where you know like there's a constant
progress and you're building upon things
that I'm talking about yeah like you go
to the moon and then you go to the bars
and then the civilization gets bigger
and bigger and there's you know I'm
talking you know I mean and the
populations grow and no that's you know
what it maybe it's because oh I
guarantee you in a hundred years from
now we'll probably be in another Dark
Age there may not even be electricity
that's how bad I think it's gonna get
yeah I mean I don't know but like I said
I find it pointless to speculate because
there are too many contingencies yeah
and maybe that's why I think that's why
because ever since I was a kid you know
I've been like a science dork especially
a biology dork like since I was a kid so
I was like super into like you know I'll
bring all about evolution and stuff so I
understand that things are not as
straightforward progression like
sometimes it's like all this stuff dies
out and then I can't see how
civilization can survive at the with the
technology that we have technologies
getting to the point to where it's
making so much abundance that you no
longer need any workers so you're making
people obsolete and they can't survive
in a work you know in a job economy
anymore because the value of labor is
vanishing and we had a population based
upon an old an older industrial
civilization where you need a lots of
people working but that's not it it's
not like that anymore
right robots are taking over so I think
what will end up happening is is that
the population will [ __ ] the popular
the pocket you know the population will
[ __ ] collapse so you'll have a very
soon you'll have a very small amount of
people it may but Lucifer principle yeah
population collapses and now there isn't
an enough population to continue a
civilization we read that book yeah and
it was that author I can't remember yeah
time ago there's no I have it over there
on them yeah though this for principle
game problem but like I said I you guys
like nearest surface again as [ __ ]
barbarians like the Saxons and the
Normans we just chop your heads off with
an axe but like I said see I feel like
even speculating about that kind of
thing is pointless because um okay did
anybody first see you know the impact of
the Internet not really
does anybody foresee the impact of
because little things can blow up into
like big things money though that
impacts the culture in ways that we
cannot anticipate we are not smart
enough to anticipate every contingency
so I feel that it is pointless this
evacuate at least more than five or ten
this is the problem I'm seeing ok I just
I find that a pointless exercise this is
the problem OSU civilizations are
basically a bunch of collections of jobs
jobs are starting to become obsolete
so when jobs become obsolete what types
of jobs are becoming out there not being
replaced with other jobs I don't think
I'm sorry about that and when that
happens this how can you have a
civilization without jobs you know I
mean a civilization is a bunch of
interlocking jobs and I think the
civilization was built upon the [ __ ]
baby boom at least here in the West I
don't know man I just I just don't I
just think it's not gonna go well we'll
see yeah but you're a like kind of
negative about [ __ ] I'm just I'm neutral
about stuff I'm just like I guess I'll
wait to see what happens I kind of think
civilizations are subtly balanced you
know what I mean when you look at what
happened you know the end the end of the
Roman period and III think we're
probably to go towards kind of like that
back into a dark age I think like I said
it's possible but who knows what else
might happen so like I said I don't I
don't I don't like really like to
speculate I know the solution is not the
solution is though space travel just get
the [ __ ] off the planet constant growth
go colonize Mars learn interstellar
travel
you know alleviate the population
density on the earth just start
spreading out
learn faster than light travel you know
you gotta you gotta push it into like a
yeah get on that yeah you can get to
Mars you can get to Mars you mad at the
moon you know Wow Mars isn't that far
it's no it's not we just use that damn
nuclear puck thing that [ __ ] that
they made back in the fifties did you
Ryan the Orion space program just like
that guy that everyone thought was Elvis
are the good stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're pretty much done with this pretty
much the only other thing I wanted to
say was the Atlas vampire case some
people have speculated that perhaps her
killer was a cop who actually killed her
and made it look super weird to like
throw off the other kind man that sound
but yeah I'm just saying oh well I
didn't say that I'm just saying yeah I'm
just saying they always come up with
that weird [ __ ] with a kid I'm gonna say
they either [ __ ] up at the post-mortem
and her blood was in there or was
sodahead kinda like a medical fetish and
do but I'm leaning toward medical fetish
cuz like I said it's weird but that's
not the weirdest thing that I was
getting it from behind not by long just
getting it from behind at the time he
knocked her out like that and he jumped
off of it goes and he hooks her up and
while she's [ __ ] unconscious pumps
her blood out of his bag yes like I said
and zips net blood go up near that bag
and he's sucking hitting it he's hitting
it Jenni watching that blood go into
that bag and then he oh he's done right
and he's a [ __ ] man I could get out of
here cuz this wasn't that good he takes
the but it takes the blood anyway but
I'll take this on anyway I might be able
to do something yeah we're and then he
never does it again because it wasn't
that good yeah I thought like that's
something and I feel like this is
somebody that had come to her before and
like I said I feel like it was one of
those frog in boiling water things where
it was kind of like he would introduce
little small aspects of the fetish like
every time so she wasn't alarmed yeah
like so maybe he should have someone
with his hopeful like paraphernalia and
she was just like and he's
yeah this is my whole deal now remember
this is only one more thing that I
brought last time and she's like okay
fine whatever and he was probably cute
so she was getting that he's getting
away with it
no Tom ah mmm like you so she was
frightened you know she's probably
putting up with these damn fetishes well
yeah because you know you look like
Quasimodo probably probably probably a
[ __ ] medical student in college dude
somebody that's yeah I kind of feel like
maybe it was yeah and then he was just
kind of like he's like I'm gonna try
this [ __ ] out he wasn't he was and then
like you said maybe he just thought it
wasn't that all that cool when he's like
mint or he started killing people in two
different ways let me try I'm gonna try
some doodad I did something much right
anyway to expand my horizons on serial
killing I think he was probably probably
talking about some kind of medical
student he was young he was kind of cute
so she [ __ ] put up with it maybe he
was a good tipper yeah I don't know
that's [ __ ] out
no it's almost always more than that who
that guy was
yeah you know she can't trust any a man
that's like they'll come at you they're
all nice and [ __ ] and then before you
know it they're punching you the back of
the head while they're [ __ ] in the
ass and then stealing all your boy yeah
so well if it killed rod but he didn't
use his fists he I don't know they just
didn't they didn't know what object it
was because it wasn't it I'm pretty
strong dude I couldn't I couldn't kill a
woman by the punch her in the back hit
my fist yeah you'd have to get it like
yeah you know that's right yeah and even
then I don't think it would do it it
probably got stopped on a woman's head
or a man's head with and and crush her
to crush their head that I couldn't yeah
you could probably if you had like heavy
boots on there you could probably kill
somebody stomping but you can stomp on
and like stomp on their neck or
something you could probably do but just
punches somebody no no you need so you
need some weight you need some weight
behind that that's what I'm thinking but
like I said because they didn't find a
weapon I don't they didn't like assume
that it was a fence they hid a weapon he
used some lightest like a baton yeah a
bar or like I said like a piper
hi poker
maybe even something you found in the
apartment they just never found it right
so yeah so that was the Atlas vampire
case like I said not a huge amount of G
unless you can speak Swedish you might
find more information about it than I
did because I only found English
language stuff and there's not a lot of
that but when we come back from the
break we're gonna take a break right now
probably refresh our drinks which will
probably be a mistake
yeah but we'll see how that goes when we
come back we will talk about the case of
Catrin decosta from 1984 as I said this
is the case that
Stieg Larsson loosely bases book The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo on so we're
going to talk about that when we come
back from the breaks we will be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright ladies and
gentlemen we are back for the second
half of episode 143 about murder in
Sweden I'm backing him in [ __ ] three
sheets to the wind you are in full 1970s
Merv Griffin mode garments all I need
man oh I want to remind you guys
something while we were talking about
the two blue yetis that we have for sale
we also have this for sale - yeah what
brand is that I don't know we did our
first couple audiobooks with with this
it wasn't really good enough it was a
$50 mic yeah it's a pretty good like you
know yeah it's got a standard good for a
web [ __ ] yeah but it's a good USB mic I
guess just for web stuff but [ __ ] man
[ __ ] we said wet fur 15 yeah 15 plus
shipping if anybody needs it just yeah
we're given we're given fans the first
crack at this if not it's going up on
yeah not if not I'm selling money big
guys like I said we just spent $230
getting a whole new get an oldy system
yeah even though we just spent all this
money on this new Yeti and it just we
need it like I said it might not be mat
compatible I think that's that might be
kind of the issue let's do it drivers it
doesn't have drivers though it's
supposed to be just plug and play that's
what annoys me
well and I have to say too that the day
that it [ __ ] the bed was the same day
okay you lost our internet well okay now
the day before this are [ __ ] we have
a sprinkler system yeah and the
sprinklers in the front we're not
working front bank wouldn't turn so all
our grass was dying and we live in like
one of those [ __ ] places with an HOA
and they will find you if your grass
looks like crap yeah they won't let my
trash on this place here's right you
can't dead grass it's got to look at
least I got my lawn I called my
sprinkler man over here we call the
sprinkler guy good man and he broke my
[ __ ] internet cable yeah he's like
he's out there working like fixing the
sprinklers and then all of a sudden our
internet goes out and Tom gets out there
and he's like hey my internet just went
out does that have anything to do with
anything you were doing and he was like
whoa well is one cable just having it
hon he was cutting he was cutting well
there's wires that run out to solenoids
that trip valves on our [ __ ] little
sprinkler banks I got a [ __ ]
sophisticated sprinkler system and he
didn't really fess up to it but I
[ __ ] I'll let it slide and I went out
cuz it's free to fix the cable company
came and fixes just that we missed cable
for we didn't have we didn't have an ID
to go to Starbucks and use their Wi-Fi
but it didn't really [ __ ] the bed I mean
you're listening to the microphone now
it's good out it's just it's it doesn't
recognize it as blue Yeti just says like
unidentified microphone yeah and we had
to like adjust the settings accordingly
and we're not the only ones that's had
this issue with blue Yeti you know it's
a good everybody loves it podcasters but
I mean they yeah this does seem to be an
Best Buy sells like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
embrace just it when it does that and I
think has something to do with Mac it
[ __ ] up the settings so when it comes
to recording audio books I don't trust
it because the consistency may not be
there that's what I mean I'm gonna go
ahead and rerecord all the recording
she's already done the audio but with a
new microphone we have coming
yeah like like I said it's a good
microphone it's just I I don't trust the
consistency for this audiobook it's for
[ __ ] podcasters you know for for
podcasting it's fine it sounds totally
fine right but for audiobook they're
very stringent about their you know
everything has to every take has to be
consistent he has to sound like it was
all done in one tank one take and I
don't trust that to do it when it's
forgetting what its settings work yeah
right so that's why that's why we're
selling it's not like it's shitty or
anything right I'm just anal about that
[ __ ] I don't want to be fun oh no I am -
I'm just saying think of those
complaints about inconsistency on the
audio so I'm we're gonna get a [ __ ]
Pro set that pro pro microphone coming
yeah we finally did and I'll sing it at
that [ __ ] and I will [ __ ] - crowds
will love it they will love it me
singing Jews priest songs
Glenn Danzig come on dig of course man
he sings Danzig in the shower yeah with
my dicks big when it's big okay so he's
big that's what I mean it's like that
was a weird thing to say I'm not I'm not
warmed up okay I gotta get my warmed up
man I've been drinking too much
yeah no show your address when I get
warmed up I can sing he can yeah yeah
it's fine
you know right Mike you know maybe I'll
buy a preamp for that we'll see we'll
see what exactly Keela tequila and I
going to the sound room got a sound
booth and we do we have a closet that we
convert gotta get that [ __ ] totally
sound to it
the closet in my office it's now a dead
right I won't do my own cover of
dissonant aggressor I want to do my own
cover of sinner from okay Jenna's /
Judas Priest a more modern version of
sinner 30 years now he's sleeping you
know yeah right yeah I know
okay I'm gonna sing some too but I
haven't decided where murder yet okay we
could do all consoles he's not he's not
buying it was that what she I know she
can sing she I asked her
saying one time and she wouldn't do it
just singling she wants to say but I
heard her saying what tell me that man
you sound pretty good to do that against
you don't on this girl she got scared
yeah I'm it's it's weird it's like it's
weird because this is social anxiety
y'all I know I have a decent poise I
mean I used to sing in a choir and I was
asked to do solos and stuff and I was
just like good no because I still have
like stage fright all right so let's
talk about our second case of murder in
Sweden
this is the murder of Catrin DaCosta
this happened in June of 1984
now Catrin decosta was also a prostitute
also a heroin addict she was 28 years
old now there was a you know a small
segment of Street in Stockholm Sweden
which is called and forgive me I'm sure
I'm butchering this but it's called I
can't believe I'm gonna attempt to
pronounce this the moms killed Mads
Gatton yeah come on would you if you
people are Swedish then please help me
out with that I see this Swedish it
written and I'm like how the hell you
[ __ ] see it's so much syllable oh my
god although J's in all those K's yeah
the dots over the word it's like I can
understand the the syllables like in
small doses but it's kind of like German
it's just kind of like they keep adding
syllables it's like knock it off it's
like break that [ __ ] up so yeah so
that's what this song and I'm not saying
again and it's honestly I wrote about
this case in faceless villain 3 which is
coming out this year and when I was
reading the audiobook I tried to
pronounce it like a bunch of times I was
just like [ __ ] it and I was like I said
some other thing because I can pronounce
it and I said it I just kept messing it
up so many times so this this area I
think it's only like 600 meters which is
a couple blocks long and it's kind of
where I laid all the prostitutes hang
out so she was kind of like a right
were there now Catrin decosta she had
apparently she had been married once
before she had a son I think her husband
was Portuguese and she had a kid but I
guess I that had not worked out and so
she would you know she had fallen on
hard times so she had turned to
prostitution now the last time she was
seen alive was June 10th of 1984 and as
she was seen getting out of a man's car
which presumably was a client and that
was I believe the last time that people
had seen her alive so she went missing
after that stage now her mom and again
like we were saying before like Oh a lot
of these people in there prostitutes and
like their families don't know where
they are but apparently they're her
mother did know where she was and like
kept track of her movements so her
mother started to get worried about her
after a day or two and reported her
disappearance to the police now
no sign of her was spotted until July
18th which if you're doing any math
that's more than a month later they
found pieces of her in a garbage bag hmm
under an overpass in a place called
Solna which was just north of the city
center I'm tells me she was killed in an
apartment or in some kind of secluded
place in a bathtub it had to be because
she was not yeah and that's how he got
her out of the apartment probably did it
in a bathtub yeah and you put them into
that plastic bag and you take them out a
little by little say are you speaking
for a spare you know what Cota
big bodies before you know with dear
well they're not not people not people
no but you know I can reduce an entire
tear down to nice few ladies and cutlets
just within an hour without spilling any
blood so you also did the Atlas vampire
case yeah went back in time to the 1930s
before you were even born
it's different though when you're doing
it to game you know with medium sized
game like deer you're doing it outside
so you have up you hang out by their
heads from a tree branch yeah I mean
yeah no doubt in the open and you got
some coolers next to you you know and
you've already filled rest them to get
them out of the field after you've
showered you got a you know cut the
belly open then ya move all the internal
organs you leave that there for the
Coyotes and the other things you know
nothing's wasted everything is eaten
yeah you know finding any time let the
other animals eat it well yeah you good
yeah this is all done with respect you
know I mean you don't waste anything you
know and they're all perfectly culled
animals the ones that have already
reproduced in there towards the end of
their life you know and they're living
in a Garden of Eden that my dad and I
created when you have hunting rights on
the land you're your [ __ ] stock in
that land with all the trees and all the
food that they like you know a man just
let him reproduce out there you just
call off a top yeah that's how it's how
Indians did that [ __ ] well that's the
best way to do that that's the
sustainable way to do it yeah yeah yeah
so this woman like I said and there was
some controversy later on over whether
her killer had been a butcher or a
surgeon but we'll get into that in a
little bit yeah so they found some parts
of her body in garbage bags in July of
1984 now a couple of weeks after that in
August they found some more parts of her
body
in a different set of garbage bags
although it should be noted that her
head was never found one breast was
never found her genitalia were never
found
so I don't know if her killer kept than
[ __ ]
I don't know but they never did find it
now she was identified through her
fingerprints as Katrina decosta as I
said 28 year old heroin addict and
prostitute now shortly after the body
was discovered
the first person that came to the
attention of police
was a doctor a pathologist in fact by
the name of teat harm or her I'm not
sure what is the M lad of the a mean I
don't know um so yeah it's it sounds
like a weird name but I'm not sure if
I'm pronouncing it right it might be her
I don't know so he was kind of a guy
that even though he denied it
um he was kind of a guy that was known
in the prostitute community like a lot
of people had seen him around there yeah
he was a regular in a pair right he had
visited many different prostitutes also
interestingly he worked at a forensics
laboratory at the Karolinska Institute
which was immediately in between the
location where the first set of bodies
had been fat or body parts have been
found and the location where the second
set of body parts Edna felt it was right
in the middle so they thought that was a
little strange also two years prior to
Katrina decosta being murdered teat arms
wife in Katherine had died of a
quote-unquote suicide now she had been
hanged but they found her hanging from a
rope like from a bedpost and she was
dressed up as if she was going out that
night which they thought was a little
strange now the coroner did rule her
death a suicide but police were always
kind of suspicious that maybe he had
killed her but they couldn't prove it
you know what I mean um so she
apparently had been attempting to
divorce him at the time so there was
kind of a motive but like I said there
wasn't a lot of physical evidence um
they also thought it was very suspicious
that when she died he was a little kind
of mad about it you know so they thought
that was a little weird also also and
Catherine that's his wife her
Father after Catrin decosta was killed
he kind of came to the police and said
you know I told you guys that I'm pretty
sure that teep killed and Catherine now
I think maybe he killed this prostitute
as well maybe you should look into that
so it was actually an Catherine's father
that brought teet harm to the attention
of authorities at the time because
thought hey I think he killed my
daughter and now I think he killed this
other person as well he worked at a
forensics laboratory he did he was a
doctor he was a pathologist yeah which
kind of makes me think that one back in
the 30s or something like that I'm not
[ __ ] on medical students like you no
good for you but there's got to be a
small percentage that are getting into
it for nefarious it's just like it's
just like the kind of thing where you
don't I mean a lot of pyromaniacs want
to join the damn fire department it's
like that guy you got pair of pedophiles
that want to be teachers I was just
going to say that for priests
perhaps some work well you will have a
lot of contact action right a lot of
contact with the thing that you're into
so yeah like I said a very small
percentage but I'm sure there's it's a
significant percentage so another weird
thing about teet was that his area of
expertise was cases of strangulation he
had written several academic papers on
the subject of strangulation and how you
could tell it apart you know from cases
where it had been a suicide for example
or where someone had strangled them like
another person it may only strangle them
so he wrote papers about that um the
first of these was published two months
after his wife was killed which seems a
little strange I'm just saying
so there was that whole thing now he
also had a co-worker who had worked with
him like a little bit his name was
Yvonne Roz I guess I'm pronouncing that
right um and he at first thought well I
don't think I don't really think teet
had anything to do
the death of his wife or the death of
this prostitute but then after he kind
of looked into it he's like hmm yeah I
think probably that was who it was a lot
of his co-workers thought he was not so
much that he was a murderer necessarily
but that he was a little creepy like in
a way that you couldn't really put your
finger on you know I mean little crazy
also they asked around a bunch of other
prostitutes that had worked with Katrina
decosta that you know kind of you know
frequented the same area um no less than
50 of them identified teet harm they're
like oh yeah he's here all the time he's
a regular with several of the
prostitutes even though his story was a
one time I had a fight with my wife and
I bought a prostitute one time just that
one time
yeah and that was it but 50 the process
has a moment of weakness that's what and
that's what he said he said it was one
moment of weakness
but all the prostitutes like I said 50
prostitute said oh yeah I know that dude
he's here all the time one of them even
said that he was violent with her
presumably that he had beaten her up so
there was that whole thing also they did
a search of teet harms home turned up
some knives and she's turned up a lot of
violence pornography so at this point
since so many people had kind of said
yeah he was kind of in the area blah
blah blah so he was arrested for the
murder of Katrina DeCosta
now while this was going on there was
also this other guy who was also kind of
coming up in the suspect list now this
was a fellow who had worked with teet
harm previously this was another doctor
he was a GP and his name is Thomas algún
now similar to a to teat harms case this
Thomas alguns wife Christina was also
attempting to divorce him
at around this time and her grounds for
divorce were that he was sexually
molesting their two-year-old daughter
Wow now they never found concrete proof
of that other than you know her say-so
and the child say so but Christina said
and the little girl said that she had
seen daddy cutting up a woman's body
with another guy and this other guy she
said looked kind of like teat harm so on
the basis of this testimony and like I
said she was only 2 so yeah how do you
have any memory take that with whatever
but like I said shoot so she was a 2
year old kid at the time like I said at
the time she was molested I don't know
how much later this was but she said
that she had seen daddy cutting up a
body with this other guy so he was
arrested also so both of these guys were
put on trial now aside from the
testimony of this 2 year old kid that
said yeah I saw daddy and this other guy
like cutting this body up there was also
this married couple and they owned a
photography shop in Stockholm and they
said okay well a while back in the
summer of 1984 we developed this set of
photographs that appeared to show body
parts like a cut-up body and these two
guys came to pick them up and these two
guys kind of looked like teeth Harmon
Thomas Augen now we asked him about
these photos because the people that
developed them were like what the [ __ ]
is this we are very upset about it and
they were like oh well it's this you
know super secret investigation please
don't say anything about it I don't know
if they said they were cops or anything
like that but I think that's what they
were trying to imply so the people that
worked at the photo at the photography
shop didn't report it to police at the
time because these guys said oh you know
this is a top secret investigation you
know we can
let anybody know we're developing these
blah blah blah so they're like okay fair
enough
but later on when they came to trial
they came forward and said yeah we
thought that was pretty weird now the
trial goes on these two doctors were
actually going to be I mean the jury
came back with a guilty verdict and then
apparently I'm not sure how the law
entirely works or you know even now or
like worked at that time but they said
okay well the judge has to finalize it
but before that happened apparently a
couple of the jurors gave interviews to
the media which was not allowed because
the final verdict had not been put in so
the whole thing was ruled a mistrial
because there had been you know
shenanigans like the jurors had been
like yeah we're gonna talk to the press
before the jury was sit before the
verdict was finalized so they basically
threw the case out but because that
happened there was a huge public outcry
because everybody at this point they had
pretty much been you know in the public
in the media they had pretty much been
well these guys are guilty of cutting up
this poor prostitute so we have to put
them back on trial because that's crazy
we can't just let them go so all of the
media attention everything like that
initiative eventually they did put them
back on trial now at the second trial
they were actually acquitted
although here's well the argument they
made was that well because they never
found the woman's head and they never
found some of the body parts they're
like well we couldn't conclusively prove
that was her that it well no they knew
it was her because the fingerprints but
they said we couldn't conclusively prove
the cause of death okay because they
never found like some of the body parts
so they're like we're presuming that
it's murder but we can't prove that
natural causes right and then so
disposed of the body and from right
right so all so they were saying the
judge said all we can convict them of
they're like we're pretty sure though
that they did cut up the body whether
they killed her or not we can't prove
that good I get what they're saying is
it could have been anything we're all
[ __ ] out getting high mmm and then
she died from an OD that's what I mean
and that they cut her up and got rid of
her because they were afraid that they
would somehow get in trouble for the OD
that's that defense has been used yeah
that's why me it sounds [ __ ] up right
but when you mean get it from that kind
of way yeah yeah I mean you would think
that you know yes the person that cut up
the body was obviously the person that
killed the person but those are two
different things like if you can't prove
the murder right there was one of those
DuPont heirs rich [ __ ] on him
one of his own private compounds shot
and killed a private trainer of his yeah
he got acquitted he said he said well
yeah it was in self-defense even though
I think and I think for a miracle he
disposed trying to dispose of that body
in a very similar way yeah I think so
but he got off yeah he got off of it
well like I said I have money of course
it helps well yeah of course if you come
from a band helps that's [ __ ]
powerful family then yeah you can get
just me saying well it was self-defence
a shot the guy yes up the fence and I
was cutting the body up because I was
afraid no one wanted to believe me man
I'd [ __ ] get life in prison for that
[ __ ] Yeah right well and I've written
about a couple cases like that where
people did like just get off just
because they couldn't quite prove rum
cause it's like oh well they died
accidentally and then I was afraid I'd
get in trouble so I buried them right
you know what I mean not cutting up
that's that's something else but so at
this particular trial they're like okay
well we couldn't actually prove that
they killed her because like I said they
could not determine cause of death
because they didn't find her entire body
they only found pieces in bags they're
like now the judge
I'm pretty sure I mean I believe that
they did cut the body up
but that's only desecration of a corpse
which isn't a huge deal and by the time
it came to trial if it was just
desecration of corpse the statute of
limitations on that had run out so
they're like there's really nothing we
can do about it we have to let them go
so the two guys got acquitted now the
media flipped out because they thought
these two guys had killed this woman and
they got away with it so there was like
a huge outcry um they actually were not
successful in getting another like a
third trial however they were successful
in getting both of their medical
licenses revoked and that was in 1991
and as far as I know they never got
their licenses back so they couldn't
practice you didn't do medically and
Sweden's got a lot of a lot of weird
cases behind it there are some other
ones maybe we ought to do one of these
days they had us they had a bunch of
Swedish black metal bands they were
going around committing murder nobody
just asked us to do a show about right
were they yeah that's a bit might be a
good time that might be a good topic
yeah that's what I said burning down
churches and killing [ __ ] DMM
Swedish black metal bands somebody
seriously it's funny that you mentioned
that because I don't even think I told
you that but but I know about that less
than a week ago somebody sent me a
message we do show we'll do a show on it
I'm gonna have to write that on my list
cuz yeah that's a good idea
yeah so even though these guys a mortise
go look up mortise I think they're two
eyes come on we should see two because
and stuff like it like [ __ ] evil elf
evil drug it might be still I don't
remember if it's on shudder or Netflix
it's a documentary called
until the light takes us yeah and it's
about that okay yeah I see that one so I
can try no I saw it on one of those two
services so I'm pretty sure it's still
there but once you took that out Swedes
like a [ __ ] shield out [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] almost like a hippie country
you know they've had problems recently
with all shits going on now but that's a
[ __ ] hippie country but there were
these black metal like a frog starts
going around with Satanism and Odin ISM
and all that kind of [ __ ] burning down
the church oh they thought it was unique
out there so they thought it's like a
boring gap yeah I guess I'd be down with
those dudes if I was [ __ ] hanging out
back in those days yeah yeah okay burn
that [ __ ] down I can see you do oh yes
Sweden burn that [ __ ] now I can see you
do they send you to jail throwing a
beating for like a couple months he was
a metal guy in the in the bit back in
the day yeah yeah yeah before before
metal before you discovered god yeah we
swear Hamlisch [ __ ] Bon Jovi came out
and I said oh I see how this shit's
going and I left him I left the metal
scene because metal started to become
about power ballads and female fans I
saw a cop nobody likes girls come on
well when you're [ __ ] 14 you know I
mean you don't want to [ __ ] 15 you
don't listen the same music that the
girls would listen to but then like a
couple years later I don't know how I
had my listened read read well then when
I was 14 or 15 I was listening to Duran
Duran but also listening to alien sex
fiend and yeah it's just it and the UK
subs there there is good no I did not
like bunch of metal you have this
[ __ ] [ __ ] with Cookie
Monster voices and [ __ ] you know I mean
that [ __ ] only as she gets old
there there there was a really good
metal bands and there probably are some
still some good metal bands but metal
metal lost its luster over time I
appreciate it more now that I'm older
like when I was growing up I feel like
especially when I was in junior high or
middle school for you younger folks
which used to be called junior right I
feel like it was kind of like the
metalheads versus the new wave and
post-punk kids yeah that's kind of what
it was I detected eventually though
because I mean I had friends in both
camps but I do feel like the metalhead
people were always
picking on and/or beating up members of
my friend group see what ended up
happening this is that metal started to
go too much la too much hair metal but
rock yeah too much [ __ ] power ballads
very female oriented I liked British
metal yeah early well it was more
working-class it was more it was more
like Punk in there yeah yeah I like I
like like the first five albums from
[ __ ] Iron Maiden
yeah I like it wasn't about pretense
right about image 70 70s and 80s
Judas Priest yeah I liked [ __ ]
merciful fate I liked [ __ ] some of
the King Diamond venom Slayer we're good
early Metallica [ __ ] no [ __ ] it Black
Sabbath who doesn't love black oh yeah
black doesn't love blacks at blacks
there like Motorhead I hear like motor
personally yeah you lend me a Motorhead
everybody loves motor it was very heavy
Blues in a certain way
who doesn't like Motorhead especially
like they're [ __ ] another perfect day
album [ __ ] bomber [ __ ] ace of
spades album overkill that album was
really good I can very first one from
Motorhead with vibrator and all that
guy's [ __ ] I can tell you like Motorhead
is one of those bands like it's kind of
like Bowie like if you don't like
Motorhead or if you like Bowie I don't
like what's the matter early horrible
deep purple was [ __ ] really good for
a while and then I'm gonna go into prog
rock even some Pink Floyd I mean
unfortunately I like some I really but
you know it was prog rock you know I
mean a product of a pretentious and [ __ ]
I know but that wasn't so much in the
[ __ ] Alan Parsons Project no [ __ ]
some of that it's not right though but
then eventually gets to the point to
where there's none of the [ __ ] are
focusing too much on guitar solos and
then all of a sudden that Sisters of
Mercy first last and always album kicked
in we're no good to heart no guitar so
now does just imagine goes that you
found that garbage can there you go
that's it lad you go tell him Jenny
legends owe me this
I was Hey
it was a metal guy and he found a
Sisters of Mercy album in a trash like
that
who threw that away I'm listening right
now let us know who you are I was there
I'm just curious
this one Michigan I was in Trenton
Michigan I just back still elbow I was
gonna return to Brazil for high school -
it was in high school I've lived a very
complicated life because I had
international tie you are so complicated
moving around all the time
and me and my buddy Mike were walking
we're smoking cigarettes and [ __ ] us
probably about 10th grade 11th grade
10th grade I was in ed to the 11th grade
twice because they didn't accept my
credits and [ __ ] so I hadn't I was in
high school for like five years it was
fun though I liked high school anyway I
was walking and I saw [ __ ] a black
album with a [ __ ] white star and a
face yeah sticking up out of it it was
here's the deal I always it looked like
I don't remember what album it was
spending so long it was not a full sized
album it was actually a EP was a EP it
only had like four or five songs on it
yeah yeah and [ __ ] we listened to it
and [ __ ] I loved it and then I went
down the record store and bought bought
first last and always
but it was sweet to me is like going
outside and it was yeah it out top of
[ __ ] garbage can and and it was in
Trenton Michigan I have to say as as
varied and you know kind of wide-ranging
as the goth subculture is which you
would know if you were involved in it as
we have been for many years sisters and
mercies first and last and always to me
if anybody says what is goth or what is
goth rock for that album right there
first and last that's I'm like start
with that because that to me is like the
quintessential oh I remember what was on
that I've had Alice on it yeah it had it
was a it was an EP with Alice yeah I
think something else was on it but it's
been so long still a great song yeah and
the album was [ __ ] the album cover
was dad
because it was outside some big her
thick carpet it was like [ __ ] Sisters of
Mercy yeah they got it for free cuz
there were other albums with it and
there were all albums that sucked
but we just saw that look at that it had
a cool album cover that looks like some
metals yeah we'll take that yeah the
rest of it was all those kind of worries
as to what the rest of it was it was
what I'm saying it was like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] okay in China remember now
you're making me [ __ ] wrack my brains
it was
she's been at that time that I didn't
like but I pray like and that was [ __ ]
like Steely Dan which I like do me there
what does he lead in his stuff like
you're riot heap and stuff it's good and
stuff like UFO and stuff like we had
free music it was yeah it was stuff like
that but I didn't like it at that time
but somebody had I saw that black album
with the [ __ ] white face the white
star and it's and I said we just I just
took it I said we'll see this sounds
like I went back to my buddy Mike's
place we never went what the [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah like I said first and
last not like to me that that kind of
like condenses everything down like I
know a lot of people say Bauhaus which I
love Bauhaus but their sound was much
more idiosyncratic they had a lot of
reggae influence they had a lot of funk
influence they had a lot of other
influences if you want something that
sounds like goth rock first and Lazarus
is a mercy first and last and always
that is it's like the distillation yeah
yeah like that's like the template going
forward that one and like everybody
ripped that [ __ ] I went into the
nineties that one album called
pornography yeah that 1982 yeah
that's it yeah those two albums honestly
pornography reminds me of that's
probably like my favorite caribou I have
to say yeah it reminds me of like taking
the Greyhound to Atlanta to go to the
first level
because I listened to it then lost my
Walkman on that journey and I still
remember that [ __ ] nowadays but I was
listening to that and Joy Division
closer was on the other side of the
cassette
yeah Joy Division's closer roles I've
got to the [ __ ] out and also [ __ ] ba
house what's the one that has [ __ ]
double dare on it and well in the flat
field had that on yet and that was their
first album the in the flat field yeah
that one
maybe mask mask is actually my favorite
mascot probably and like I said it's all
over the map there's reggae on it
there's you know Rasta hunted reggae
it's yeah it's like all over the place
but still it hangs together yeah I think
that's easily their best album even
though it's like it's like their most
diverse but that's why I said that I
don't consider them a quintessentially
goth rock band because they had so much
other [ __ ] going on all four of them had
wildly divergent music days and you can
tell that if you listen to them because
it's just like kind of all over the
place I love you just want to lay back
have sex of course you put [ __ ] boob
Billy Idol [ __ ] rebel yell I [ __ ]
love it really sex music though cocaine
is involved if cocaine is involved in
that would be rebel yell okay alright
alcohol are there's something about that
album I've always loved that album
it is good yeah I listened to it
recently and I was a boy design this is
awful simplistic the way it was recorded
that's alright though that's just the
way it was back in the eighties I found
it like I well here's the thing like I
know we're getting off on it
do-do-do-do-do-do yeah so after midnight
are you feeling alright
oh yeah and back to back seriously what
if you see and feel my sex attacks again
I love that flesh for fantasies we call
her guys we have a well we haven't been
for a while but we
we would always go to the 80s night at
independent bar here in downtown Orlando
which if you're around here you should
go because I love that place but um we
would yeah we always danced a Billy Idol
it's a I love eighties music I love
honestly and I feel like I had a lot of
like eclectic music taste when I was a
kid like younger like I like about the
chameleons
I like 60s music I like I like old blues
like from the 20s 30s 40s I like
broccoli from the 50s I love that kind
of that [ __ ] I love Elvis I love all
that [ __ ] and um but as I've gotten
older I feel like I've gotten like more
appreciation for [ __ ] I didn't like so
much growing up yeah I feel like I can
appreciate it more yeah looking back on
it it's a lot better than it was yeah
I think time like kind of gives you like
seriously we cuz we go to movies all the
time and I've seen I'm super excited
this is this funny I'm super excited
about seeing Rocket Man that lived on
biopic and every time I see the trailer
which is a lot because they show it all
the time I'm like every time I see this
trailer and I whispered this number the
other day I'm like every time I see this
trailer I'm reminded how [ __ ] Brad
tiny dancer is yeah well it's better
Brad song I love that album John was
extra soon and I didn't like him at the
time but looking back on it yeah a
fantastic performer and the music was
really good although I have to say even
in the 80s when I'm still standing came
out we see we were associated with our
parents generation right yeah I think
that's like oh that's old people maybe
like I like all the new we've like Adam
Ant I like Susan the Banshees I like
that kind of [ __ ] okay
so getting back to teat harm and Thomas
I'll give the two guys that were accused
of murdering Catrin decosta they got off
in the end
and even though about probably half of
the Swedish population think that they
probably did it and got away with it um
I'm not sure where I stand on it like I
said I wrote about this for faceless
villain
and it does sound like I don't know if
they had motivation but they for sure
you know kind of lied about particularly
teeth he kind of lied about
oh I never go to prostitutes well one
time I went there but then all the other
prostitutes like 50 prostitutes like I
said like recognized him so I thought
that was a little weird now however I
should say that teet harm did actually
attempt suicide in 1985 and I think he
tried to hang himself or strangle
himself or something but he lost like
most of his hearing during his suicide
attempt and he has up until now or at
least up until the late 2000s I don't
know if he's still alive or not has
maintained his innocence so I'm not sure
how that goes now there was another guy
that was possibly a suspect that does
sound kind of intriguing now this was a
guy he was originally from Poland and he
was a butcher which you know that might
have been kind of relevant to the way
the body was cut up his name was
stanislav ganor cow now he had been in a
mental institution since 1974 now he was
in there because the crime he was put in
there for was he strangled a woman and
then cut her body up and put the parts
in garbage bags suspect like I said that
sounds a little familiar
now police did look into him but for
whatever reason I'm not entirely sure
why they dismissed him as a suspect I
don't know if it was because they
couldn't prove he was there at the time
or some other reason yet maybe he was
someplace else or maybe he was
incarcerated I don't know but so they
dismissed him as a suspect even though
that MO sounds pretty similar you know
hey I'm just gonna cut up this woman and
put her in garbage bags just like this
guy did but so that was another guy that
it could have been so maybe it wasn't
these
doctors but because of the kind of you
know media circus that surrounded these
two guys like in the ensuing years after
the crime like I said this first time in
1984 that was kind of what inspired
Stieg Larsson to write Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo where he was kind of
coming from and from a perspective of
there's these powerful men and they're
kind of preying on these women and no
one's really doing anything about it
because that's kind of how it seemed at
the time so that's where that idea came
from whether these two doctors actually
did this or not I don't really know and
I'm like I said I'm not taking a stand
on that because maybe they didn't do it
they did seem like they had some other
sketchy [ __ ] going on but you know I
don't know if they actually killed and
cut up this woman or not it actually
kind of to me sounds more likely that
the second dude dude that was like a
butcher but I don't know I wasn't there
so I don't really know now this Polish
guy to the butcher they also did find
his name in katrin's diary along with
other names of her clients and whatnot
so he had actually been there some of
the other prostitutes recognized him
yeah he came around here sometimes they
did find his hair I believe on maybe on
her body but it that's the kind of thing
though he was kind of a regular customer
it seemed like at least according to her
diary so I had many [ __ ] that's what
I mean right so it could be argued that
you know that was just like I said you
can't really prove the heart of tale
with this [ __ ] with all this transient
people and all these prostitutes yeah
all these people come and going so I
think sex with each other these [ __ ]
nasty people right it's just like you
know it's if you have to do that for
money it's like [ __ ] man I don't I don't
think I could do that
you get sick of it real quick well I'm
already sick of it and I haven't even
done it you're sick of money are you
sick of your sick sex no I'm saying I
wouldn't treat you sick of sex already
never no thank you no wouldn't know what
I'm saying is that even the thought of
having to
like oh I have no idea axis and I have
to like blow dudes for money and already
sick of that [ __ ] I think starve
honestly starving sounds nicer than like
blowing some strange it's like that it
was like that movie we saw the other day
[ __ ] the hustle well if you're
good-looking all that allows you to do
is that what is it you basically have to
trade sex for money yeah you know what
if you're but if you're a what is it a
if you're a common good woman you can
just run well you just get it without
right yes having to do that right yeah
yeah because that's you know spoiler
alert that's what she was doing in that
movie she that was a funny movie it was
very funny yes she was she was just kind
of like getting people to like getting
rich dudes - like proposed to her yeah
Anstey without having to put out but
then she would like do weird [ __ ] and
they'd just be like no forget it yeah
they're all in the wedding office she's
keeping the ring of her time and usually
that's a good scams like half a million
dollar wedding rings I'm like I can do
all kind of crazy [ __ ] to run us off
yeah if I need it - I would rather do
that yeah I'd rather do some like
con-artists [ __ ] then like no seriously
it's like honestly mad respect to women
that are like prostitutes or escorts or
something I could not [ __ ] do that no
way like dude shows up and it's like you
have to blow this dude because they have
to that's what I mean that's what you
start making the money they start buying
the body mods to make more and more
money all these porn stars are also
hookers yeah the [ __ ] the porn movies
is the [ __ ] demo for and plus I don't
have a really good cuz here's the thing
this my face right here it's like it
pretty much conveys every emotion that's
like going through my head at the time
yes that's what I mean so like if I
think that you're gross or whatever
that's totally gonna show it's like yeah
super awesome yeah look at that awesome
dick that you have my face is go
oh yeah that's someone who's just care
about is the picture I can't and what's
funny not a good actress I'm not and
then and then these same women got
boyfriends and then the boyfriends tell
them to forgive you you know how much
did you make tonight honey
that's some [ __ ] weird [ __ ] I always
thought that was kind of weird too I
mean it's not weird I don't know it is
kind of weird
I would I would find it well well when
we were at [ __ ] southern Knights with
that [ __ ] weird scene it was going on
there yeah that was a weird scene a lot
of those it's a bar but they had like a
feather finish nights and they have snow
we used to go there are some famous porn
stars there yes okay we're not gonna
mention when I mention the name but we
yeah we know they did we know the deal
with them you know friends with them I
guess you could say Haim in a while but
Freddie's girls yeah yeah really nice
girl but it's funny what they do and how
they make money and then when you look
at the boyfriend you go like that's the
boyfriend yeah yeah well the two of them
had one boyfriend yeah I shared and um
they started fighting with each other
though that's not a thing anymore yeah
that what it was a thing for a while
buddies were these were this situation
kind of disintegration for big-titty
Finnish girls I mean they're [ __ ]
yeah like titties the size of beach
balls yeah like freakish like freakishly
they're both cool though they yeah but
like I said super night I mean super
super sweet girl I'm gone poor hub and
see all that [ __ ] and you see some of
these [ __ ] these [ __ ] beach ball
size days we're talking about yeah and
like I said that's why I would never
[ __ ] on people to do that because
they're people like we know soup yeah we
know some people that do that yeah and
they're super super nice but you never
another dork and you would never never
know what it's like they're totally
gonna see the face and not the body you
go like like you're a [ __ ] porn star
really okay but yeah they're super cool
you can talk to me but all this kind of
stuff and like later on you find out
it's like oh yeah I do like you know
webcam porn and like I do this on the
other and I'm sure there was more yeah
yeah so there's like all this [ __ ] going
on so like I said I'm I've always been
like very laid-back it's like people can
do whatever
hurting people I don't really care but
it's like interesting particularly being
like coming as we do like from the goth
scene the fetish scene and stuff like
that people are up to all kind of [ __ ]
and you don't know about it and even
like when they tell you afterwards is
like okay you never would have but you
just roll with it you just roll with it
that's that's how that [ __ ] rolls it's
just like I said most of them are very
nice
it's just case wrapped up it is yeah but
like I said that's pretty much more
that's Curry warming up man wrapped it
look at him I told you he's a very good
cook he made curry today yeah all right
so we're wrapping up this case even
though I'm sure we probably didn't talk
about it except for maybe 80% of the
time we talked about those murders this
shows gotta be two hours long it
probably is it
yeah probably all right so we're gonna
wrap up episode 143 about murder in
Sweden Atlas vampire and the Katrina
cast a case hope you guys enjoyed it
even though we went off on several
different drunken tangents that's we
usually do but apparently and like I
said you guys like that other than the
one or two people that are like when you
guys get you the tapping you can go to
ebay and find you go to Wikipedia fie
these topics we're deliver in this in a
very [ __ ] this special way because
you guys are commuting or you baby
headphones on and you're taking your
time and we're talking it's like
professional friends we're just talking
to you guys nice talking yeah sometimes
we go off on tangents yeah that's just
how it happens yeah if you just want the
facts like I said go read the [ __ ] on
Wikipedia and quit complaining to me
because I'm kind of sick we're talking
your asses to sleep or talking you
through your workday and we know what's
going on you guys are communicate with
us yeah it's like amsr wait what is that
that's that [ __ ] where they [ __ ]
rubbin on that [ __ ] microphone and
talking to your ears and oh yeah it's
like a paranormal and that's our kind of
deal but it's different they got time
they won't need people talking to them
okay yeah making them laugh that's what
I mean yeah yeah even though I hope I'm
talking without like mispronouncing
check yes you know the case is only part
of the show
[Laughter]
longer though oh he gets like this every
time you drop forbidden don't forget all
these microphones that we're selling if
we got any podcasters out yeah if you
guys want we got Brandon [ __ ] run
podcast we got even like for all we know
conspirator normal might need some new
microphones yeah if you want a blue blue
yeti you've got to or we have this other
this $50 one that yeah you can have that
cheap so if you want one just like
contact us and we will like I said if I
don't know them I'll just put them on
eBay whatever they're working and it
came from course good homes they're not
abused this isn't some nasty-ass place
with dog hair and [ __ ] up no it's just
regular good stuff is sitting here it's
ready to be used by somebody it's just
that it was we need a microphone that
can podcast and do audio book and I
wouldn't recommend any of these
microphones for audio book podcast there
okay well I'm like I said I'm not sure
they're entirely Mac compatible the
problem if you're gonna use blue Yeti
with a Mac you got to do manual
adjustments to make sure the sound
quality and I don't have time for that
yeah a no time for that [ __ ] alright so
we are ramping up a a herd of 43 about
Atlas vampire and the Katrina cost a
case hope you guys enjoyed our tangent
filled excursion into the true crime you
know whatever it was and remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe on
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation that
would be much appreciated
remember our last movie review was 12
monkeys by Terry Gilliam so go check
that out also our regular episodes go up
every Tuesday and our movie
retrospectives go up every Friday 13
o'clock matinee three new movies in the
theater that comes out every Sunday if
you are a patron you will get access
to all of these the day before they come
out so he'll be all special and [ __ ] so
check that that's a good check that
that'll do it for this episode we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]